time cette année dix vit sa couverture
en quatre pour des journalistes menacés
dans leur pays
le magazine titre de guardians les
gardiens et la guerre à la vérité le
premier hommage et pour jamal khashoggi
ce saoudien assassinées et disparues au
consulat de son pays à istanbul il
décrivait dans le washington post
toutes les dérives brutales et les
violations du régime dirigé par le
prince héritier mohammed bin salman est
soutenue malgré l'épreuve par le
président donald trump
au nom des intérêts économiques
américains en arabie saoudite times pose
la question si on tue des journalistes
comme khashoggi à qui peut-on faire
confiance pour dire la vérité
la deuxième manche est celle des
journalistes du capitole gazette ce
quotidien d'annapolis au maryland où en
juin dernier un homme a abattu cinq de
ses journalistes
l'assassin en voulait au journal pour
avoir apporté ses démêlés avec la
justice pour le harcèlement d'un
camarade de classe
la philippine mary rsa documente dans
son journal web rappelé la guerre aux
narcotrafiquants et les exécutions
extrajudiciaires commises par le régime
du président populiste
rodrigo doute ernie els ont fait douze
mille victimes depuis un an
selon human rights watch à le rappeler
est poursuivi pour fraude fiscale et
maria rsa risque 10 ans de prison
au myanmar ce sont deux jeunes reporters
de l'agencé reuter emprisonné pour avoir
apporté la mort de 10 membres de la
minorité musulmane rohingya qui a au
soho et wallonnes ont été condamnés à 7
ans de prison
les assassins à une peine de 10 ans de
prison au vietnam où la blogueuse nous
yens ghosn ou queen emprisonné pour
avoir critiqué le parti communiste est
ensuite envoyé en exil au mexique la
reporter radio douchina parra est d'un
groupe de mères à retrouver leur fils
capturé par les narcotrafiquants qui la
menace le turc can dündar rédacteur en
chef du journal d'opposition cumhuriyet
sans fuite son pays après une tentative
d'assassinât
il y en a d'autres deux cent soixante
deux journalistes ont été emprisonnés en
2017 et on s'attend à des chiffres
semblables cette année le magazine
souligne que de plus en plus à travers
le monde et aussi aux états unis la
vérité est menacée mais qu'il reste
malgré tout des journalistes pour la
défendre
jean michel leprince a du canada
montréal